hello next week in front of
strasbourg woods for the very last
plenary session before the
european elections which will be held from 22 to 25
may next here are the main topics
on the agenda of deputies
one hundred years after the start of the first
world war europe  remembers
what lessons can be drawn from the conflict which has
ravaged the continent and left more than 18
million dead MEPs will
debate the issue on Wednesday in the hemicycle,
also an opportunity to recall
that Europe has succeeded in establishing peace
within  its borders for more than 60
years
a major debate is expected on the
banking union after the agreement reached
in March between parliament and the
member states how to bail out banks in the
event of bankruptcy without charging
taxpayers a fund of 55
billion euros will be made available, an
amount that is far too small, according to some,
for others it is prevention that
must be the priority, in
particular through monitoring  stricter launches
of european banks by the
central bank but will the system
really be effective mps answer
tuesday
every day hundreds of new
products enter the european market
how to ensure that all these
objects comply with european standards and
do not risk  to endanger
consumers
the deputies will vote on Wednesday to
know if a label specifying
doubiens each product will have to be
compulsory it will also be a question of
putting in place heavier penalties
for the resellers of
dangerous products toys in particular
how to further reduce the
consumption of bags  handy plastic
can be found in
most supermarkets in europe
consumption levels vary
considerably from one state to another
so the consumption of the seven
best performing member states
represents only 20% of the
average consumption  from across Europe
MEPs will vote on Thursday on  r
new measures so that the effort is
shared by all on
Tuesday there will also be a question of the health
of plants and animals on Wednesday
it is the mobility of workers which
is on the agenda as well as the question
of supplementary pensions see
you there  next week on euros
by tv for more information on these
topics and until then have a good week